this morning around 100 pro-democracy
protesters are barricaded inside a Hong
Kong University in a tense standoff with
police they're facing desperate
conditions after fighting police
yesterday with Molotov cocktails
catapults and bows and arrows
ramie Inocencio is just outside that
university so Raymie
good morning as nightfall comes what's
the situation there good morning yes we
are just outside the campus of
Polytechnic University right behind me
here and just trying to figure out
what's been happening right now we're
trying to know how many people are
inside it's estimated maybe 100 to 200
protesters are there but it really is
tough to know because the several
buildings are basically a labyrinth of
rooms and corridors and quarters that
people can try to hide if police did
really try to raid the campus so it
really is impossible to know the mangled
barricaded main entrance to Hong Kong
Polytechnic University is anything but
welcoming and campus life is littered
with the debris of conflict in the
makeshift infirmary volunteer medics
tells CBS News they've treated more than
100 injuries the worst a collapsed lung
from an officer's rubber bullet food
supplies are dwindling but cooks in the
canteen keep frying up rice to feed the
last of the resistance this is the heart
of the University's campus defences
right in front of me are hundreds of
Molotov cocktails here the smell of the
flammable material is very much in your
face as the violence intensified Monday
many protesters tried to escape in
different ways descending daringly over
bridges are dropping into dirty sewers
but Tuesday afternoon many protestors
cold hungry and wrapped in thermal
blankets surrendered and walked off
campus still others chose to stay like
John and Jackie how are you feeling
right now after three days being
here very down do you feel that you've
lost this university is not the last
last battle yeah you can say just is
another battlefield now anyone under 18
was let go but anyone 18 and older was
immediately arrested by police earlier
at a press conference chief executive
Carrie Lam said at least 400 adults have
been arrested so far they could be
detained and charged but if they are not
charged they could be set free but right
now it is just any anyone's guess as to
what could happen moving ahead
Gail I'll say six months and Counting
still no sign of a solution there thank
you very much ray me
innocencio reporting for us from Hong
Kong